Most Star Trek fans can agree that there are
few characters in the series quite as revered
as The Next Generation's Captain Jean-Luc
Picard.
“Isn’t there something else you have to
do?”
Now, we've finally gotten some concrete news
on Patrick Stewart's return to Starfleet in
Star Trek: Picard.
While the producers of Star Trek: Picard have
been surprisingly forthcoming with info regarding
the series, mum's the word on when exactly
the series will be beaming onto the CBS All
Access streaming platform.
That will come as a bit of a bummer for die
hard Picard fans who've been waiting since
2002's disappointing tenth Star Trek movie,
Star Trek: Nemesis, to see what's become of
their beloved Captain.
But even if the exact premiere date of Star
Trek: Picard was not revealed in that Hall
H information dump at San Diego Comic-Con,
the show's producers did unveil the full trailer
for the series, which promises that Picard
will once again boldly go where no man has
gone before sometime in 2020 — plenty of
time to run through all of TNG again, and
even knock out a little Deep Space Nine as
well.
Maybe skip the movies though.
TNG is timeless, but the feature-length follow-ups?
They haven't aged that well.
So far we've got two glimpses of the Picard
series — a brief teaser, and a more involved
trailer just a few months later.
The teaser took us back to Picard's family
vineyard, which he retired to sometime after
the events of TNG, implying that the show
would be picking up more or less where the
series left off — movies not included.
The full trailer doubled-down on the "Old
Man Picard" concept, giving us a substantial
peek at the surprising things in store for
the Starfleet icon.
There's a lot to unpack in the trailer, including
some unanswered questions.
It seems that Picard will begin the series
in retirement, making wine in the French countryside.
But he's called back to duty to help a mysterious,
and possibly dangerous young woman, whose
story somehow leads him back to the hallowed
halls of Starfleet.
One of the most pressing questions on the
minds of TNG fans when the news of the Picard
series broke was when exactly the series would
take place.
"5,000 years in the future."
It's been almost 20 years since we last saw
Picard on the bridge of the Enterprise, in
2002 with TNG's cinematic swan song, Star
Trek: Nemesis - no one's favorite Star Trek
movie.
When we last left the crew, they'd narrowly
escaped a galactic beatdown at the hands of
the ruthless Picard clone Shinzon.
They'd also seen Jonathan Frakes' Will Riker
leave the Enterprise to take command of the
USS Titan, and witnessed the tragic demise
of Brent Spiner's Data.
Matching up with the real-life time gap, the
Picard series will take place about two decades
after the events of Nemesis.
The years away may not have been particularly
kind to Jean-Luc, who seems more than a little
haunted in his retirement, with apparently
no one but a new pet dog keeping him company.
So it's probably good news for Picard that
the peculiar young woman shows up and sets
him on a more adventurous path, with a whole
new crew to command.
Picard won't be returning to the bridge of
the Enterprise with his TNG crew in tow.
The captain's former crew are likely still
around; they've just moved onto new things,
and new adventures in the years since they
worked as Starfleet officers under Picard's
command.
As it happens, Picard may not be rolling with
Starfleet at all for this new, secretive mission.
While we're not 100% certain how or if Picard
will return to Starfleet proper, we know that
he'll get a new ship to command, evidently
with a whole new crew of fresh faces from
Starfleet's next next generation.
We don't know much about the crew yet, but
there are some talented actors bringing the
characters to life.
The new faces include Santiago Cabrera from
Big Little Lies as Cristobal Rios, Alison
Pill from Scott Pilgrim vs. The World as Dr.
Agnes Jurati, Michelle Hurd from Ash vs. Evil
Dead as Raffi Musiker, Harry Treadaway from
Penny Dreadful as Narek, and newcomer Evan
Evagora as the Romulan Elnor.
So you can rest assured that there will be
plenty of intrigue among the show's supporting
players.
The show may be called Picard, but with a
cast like this, it looks like it won't be
just about him.
We've long suspected that at least a few ghosts
of Star Treks past would be making appearances
in Picard.
The series' first full trailer confirmed two
surprising additions to the cast: TNG's Data,
last seen being blown to pieces in the cold
vacuum of space, and Star Trek: Voyager's
Seven of Nine, last seen… well, on Voyager.
Needless to say, fans have a few questions
about how these two characters will fit into
the Picard series.
"I'm just a man who is looking for answers."
On one level, the return of Brent Spiner's
inquisitive android makes sense.
Data was one of TNG's best-loved characters,
who developed a complex and rich relationship
with Picard over the course of that show's
seven seasons.
But with the character apparently having died
at the end of Nemesis, how is he returning,
and why?
It's hinted at the movie's end that the identical
android B-4 can access Data's personality
and memories, but is that what's happening
in Picard?
"I do not know."
As for Seven of Nine, we frankly don't have
a clue what role she'll play in the Picard
series, because she and Picard have never
shared the screen before.
But they do both share the struggle of having
once been part of the Borg Collective.
What we do know is that a Borg ship is prominently
featured in the trailer, so there's the potential
that Seven of Nine will offer some insight
on the state of her former Collective.
However she factors into Picard, it's nice
to have Jeri Ryan back in character, as she
was frequently the most interesting part of
Star Trek: Voyager.
"The robot has been neutralized.
May I leave now?"
Along with Spiner and Ryan, we now know Jonathan
Del Arco will also appear, reprising his role
as Borg scout Hugh from The Next Generation.
For those who don't remember Hugh's memorable
TNG arc, the Borg scout was found stranded
and critically injured in deep space.
He was brought aboard the Enterprise, under
protest from Picard, and nursed back to health.
Picard initially sought to use Hugh as a weapon
to destroy the Borg once and for all, but
Hugh's surprising ability to comprehend human
individuality led Picard to cancel his xenocidal
plans.
Though he doesn't show up in the trailer,
it's been confirmed that TNG alum Jonathan
Frakes will indeed appear on screen as the
Captain Picard's trusted "Number One," Will
Riker.
He'll also be directing some episodes of the
show.
"You are correct.
It's fact."
Frakes will also be joined on screen by Marina
Sirtis, the Betazoid Deanna Troi.
Hey, anyone know what Levar Burton, Gates
McFadden, and Michael Dorn are up to?
'Cause it sure feels like Picard is trying
to get the TNG band back together.
"To absent friends."
Of all the questions raised by the Picard
trailer, one of the biggest surrounds the
identity of a whole new character - the mystery
woman Picard is trying to help.
After a two-decade absence, one assumes that
not just anybody could lead Picard back to
Starfleet.
Deepening the mystery, the woman appears to
have a particular affinity for Jean-Luc.
"She came to me for help."
Of course, we promptly see her putting the
smack down on a couple of armed guards, and
we also get some ominous warnings about her
from a couple of characters, so we're not
entirely sure how much protection she actually
needs.
For now, that's really all we know about the
new character, outside of the fact that her
name is Dahj.
She's played by actress Isa Briones.
Aside from a "blink and you'll miss it" appearance
in 2018's Assassination of Gianni Versace
series, she doesn't have many big credits
to her name, so here's hoping she gets a chance
to make the most of her Star Trek debut.
Over his legendary career with Starfleet,
Picard went toe-to-toe with quite a few antagonists,
from the domineering Borg to the mischievous
Q. As far as who Jean-Luc and company will
be facing off against in Star Trek: Picard,
we still aren't entirely sure - but it's tempting
to think it's the Borg.
We clearly see one of those dreaded Borg cubes
in the trailer, and Picard also has a very
specific past with the fearsome Collective.
And appearances by Seven of Nine and Hugh
would lead us to think the Borg will figure
prominently in whatever interstellar ruckus
Picard finds himself entwined in.
But the trailer also gives us clear shots
of what appear to be re-designed Romulan warbirds
- ships from a species Picard has more than
a prickly past with.
It will be interesting to see what shifts
there have been in the status quo since the
last time we visited the Alpha Quadrant with
Jean-Luc.
Will Picard find himself in another standoff
with the Borg?
Are the Romulans trying to make a fearsome
comeback?
Is Shinzon back as well???
For now, we'll just have to wait and see.
While Picard is technically picking up where
The Next Generation left off, the series has
more in common, both in its look and behind
the scenes, with the other modern-day Star
Trek series: Star Trek Discovery.
Both series are being produced by Alex Kurtzman,
and the shows are also set to be streaming
partners on the CBS All Access platform, with
Picard seemingly taking the same stylishly
cinematic approach to Star Trek as Discovery
does.
And Star Trek has never been a series to shy
away from a crossover, either.
Many fans are wondering, will Picard and Disco's
disparate crews cross paths on the small screen?
"I'm not certain of that now, Captain."
While CBS may have some sort of crossover
in mind down the road for these two Star Trek
shows, it's a safe bet that Picard and Discovery
won't intertwine immediately.
A lot of that has to do with the current plot
arc of Discovery, going into its third season
- so here's your spoiler warning if you haven't
seen what's up yet.
After a head-spinning twist in the season
two finale that saw Discovery's crew leap
1,000 years into the future via a time-spanning
wormhole, the timelines of the two series
would seem to be way too far apart for a crossover
to work - not that that's stopped the series
in the past.
So while we wouldn't be surprised if the series
collided sometime down the road, it seems
likely that we'll have to wait for Picard
to find its sea legs first.
Maybe in a second season.
But we might be getting ahead of ourselves.
With Picard's first season yet to have a launch
date, it's still a little early to speculate
about a potential season two.
The series will be starting off with a ten-episode
run, following plot threads that have yet
to be fully revealed.
But though a lot about the series' nitty-gritty
details remains unknown, there seems to be
a lot of goodwill for the nostalgia-inducing
series, considering just how beloved Picard
is as a character - for now, at least.
If things go well for the series, and the
show goes over with the fans, there's every
reason to think a second season is in the
cards.
But part of that decision rests on the fans,
and how audiences respond to the series.
Will viewers respond well to seeing Picard
take to the stars again?
Or will they end up feeling like everyone
should've just let the guy stay retired?
Either way, the show's fate is in your hands.
If you want Picard to continue on after these
initial episodes, you'll have to make it so.
"You are a truly clever person."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Trek
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.